matt tacite a beaucoup changé de look on
a fait une frise de thé bout parce que à
toujours était beau gosse toi moi tu as
une chance tu vois c'est un an si c'est
vraiment on va commencer avec toi tout
jeune qui était déjà habitué à être
incognito face aux paparazzi regarde
javert ce petit palmier la voix c'est
ouais mais lui c'est un garçon semblait
une punition ça quand même non c'est à
dire oh toi tu as toujours été frais en
fait jamais connu le bail de tu te dis
je sens que je suis seul je dois avoir
des dossiers quittera non à balard
regarda prêt à tomber je te jure frère
est un peu plus casquette bas gear
regarde et bâti est magnifique et m'a
dit non mais sans rival effrayant on
dirait la normalement c'est les gars
vous savez ricky ou la belle soeur et
frère il a déjà cet âge là tu dois voir
la cause je crois que j'étais en sixième
agen 6 à dire et je fais je fais petit
petit ouais parce qu'on abuse en sixième
alors attends regarde après la faute de
quelques années ont atterri tout doit
regarder la télé ah ouais il est pour
contrôler le clip delme contrer grâce
devant la mairie ne l'est pas non ça
reste lyon arrêté sa part la meilleure
alors là tu avais la barre ce qu'on
appelle à la scala laspalès ce qu'on
appelle dans le milieu là robert hue la
robert hue exactement là c'était voilà a
way
j'adore à moi c'est ce que les blacks
j'adore dès 2008 c'est qu'on va leur
faire soigner mieux là bas une 2,8 à
l'arrêt et magnifique qui tombe à pic
pas là l'art est le thème d'un matt
pokora toit d'autres super mais ça veut
dire qu ils t'adorent je sais à web est
un très grand joueur de foot thème
l'antenne ouais et lui et on dira vrai
joueur s'est laissé pousser pour robin
des bois les cheveux c'est bien mais les
mecs des vestiaires aussi que le
problème avec matt pokora j'vous jure
tirez-vous qu'ils m'ont gardé ses
carreaux on essaie de trouver des salles
photo on n'a pas trouvé
donc je te retrouverai moi je tends vers
un ta prochaine fois tu ma mère m'a dit
vas y regardez regardez
il ya un autre des mines et garder ouais
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal aussi loué
sa mère et enfin ma préférée là c'était
quand il voulait se mettre à la moto
j'aime bien c'est plus là c'est plus
c'est maintenant un seuil à ces au
défilé balmain sayad ya six mois
mais je reconnais du balmain la crise de
la tête aux pieds fg le pis pour cet été
en ballon va citer d'autres marques mais
quand on a battu des marques
concurrentes de balma avec noiséens auto
gémeaux et qui a eu tort et je suis un
homme human pierre voilà merci s'il vous
plaît fnaim on n'est pas dans votre
émission on entend que vous ne
bénéficiez pas de relater vraiment de
mauvaise foi mon petit bonne alors je
vais dire à la régie de calais ça et je
vous le dit valérie 6 à 6 et vous ça va
très mal et tu as voulu m'attaquer mon
petit bonhomme bravo parce que vous avez
tout de suite dénoncé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]